a
el gobierno argentino creó la plataforma
web argentina punto gov.ar verano para
obtener un certificado de circulación y
acceder a los requisitos de ingresos
específicos de cada provincia del país
para las vacaciones de este verano 2020
2021 marcadas por la pandemia de kobe 19
esos requisitos pueden incluir permisos
provinciales test de kobe negativo y un
seguro de salud que cubra esa enfermedad
en el país están habilitados los vuelos
internos los traslados en vehículos
particulares y se están habilitando
progresivamente los buses y trenes de
larga distancia el turismo en argentina
también está abierto para los ciudadanos
y residentes de países limítrofes por
otro lado para promover el turismo
interno el gobierno nacional lanzó un
plan llamado pre viaje que ofrece un
crédito de 50% de lo que gasten a
quienes adquieran servicios del sector
en forma anticipada
[Música]
ya los parques de calles y ciudades
costeras de sudáfrica se empiezan a
llenar de ciudadanos que están
disfrutando de las vacaciones y de las
actividades de cierre de año ya está
entrado el verano aquí en el hemisferio
austral y las temperaturas siguen
aumentando en sudáfrica el gobierno ha
puesto sus esperanzas de una ligera
reactivación económica en el turismo que
atrae esta época del año se han
flexibilizado las condiciones para los
visados para algunos ciudadanos europeos
que vengan durante varios meses y
también se ha abierto el espacio aéreo
para vuelos locales y también para
internacionales sin embargo esta semana
el ministro de salúd zweli mkhize
anunció que sudáfrica está oficialmente
experimentando una segunda ola de la
pandemia aunque durante semanas
sudáfrica no superó los dos mil casos
diarios esta semana se registraron más
de seis mil casos en un solo día
uno de los focos de infección es la
provincia del cabo occidental cuya
capital la ciudad del cabo- y uno de los
focos turísticos tanto del país como del
continente antes del anuncio del
ministro de salud el ministerio de
turismo había lanzado una campaña que
promueve el turismo local anticipando
que el turismo internacional no será tan
alto como suele ser en esta época del
año y como lo ha sido en años anteriores
pero también ha hecho énfasis en que se
deben seguir estrictamente las medidas
de bioseguridad
[Música]
inicia el verano en australia y en
cuanto a la pandemia no hay preocupación
porque el país ya vive la nueva
normalidad con cifras de contagio muy
bajas con el comercio totalmente abierto
con muy pocas restricciones vigentes y
además con toda la población a la espera
de la llegada de la vacuna lo que sí
tiene preocupadas a las autoridades
australianas es que con la llegada del
verano también llega la temporada de
incendios forestales y con temperaturas
superiores a los 40 grados centígrados
recordemos que la última temporada de
incendios dejó 26 personas fallecidas 3
billones de animales afectados y 18
millones de hectáreas consumidas por las
llamas esta temporada fue calificada por
expertos como una de las tragedias
ambientales más importantes de la
historia reciente y por eso le han hecho
un llamado al gobierno federal de
australia para que inviertan más
recursos en combatir el cambio climático
esta época de incendios forestales se
extenderá hasta marzo que es cuando
inicia el otoño y también empiezan a
descender las temperaturas
[Música]